pionnier du genre de structure spock et
jason jones call me direz vous pourquoi
j'ai ce noeud et pourquoi on se retrouve
sur le jeu alors qu'il avait terminé le
dlc car à marie-rose pétrole c'est une
sorte de variante de la fin du jeu voilà
c'est parti alors là l'histoire voilà
c'est que l'ascenseur par aux couilles
totalement comme ça les chambres des
fils à la vitesse de la lumière
et on sait pas où ça nous mène voilà on
se retrouve en sortant de l'ascenseur
est ce qu'on a envie de chialer
totalement après c'est l'horreur
mignotte pourrait l'oublier ça fait
plusieurs escales une arme
oui en nature l'âge plus tard avec
laquelle on avait tué des desserts ou
déchets plus des volants des
cerfs-volants à la il détend déjà
l'ambiance avec des blagues lourdes à la
barre qu'il n'y a pas marqué deux
chambres en haut à droite ça ça
m'inquiète
on va avancer au voilà le petit esprit
je sais pas comment tu as fait pour
descendre jusqu ici je me souviens même
pas qu'ils avaient des chambres ici
ouais c'est comme ça at en abuser est ça
se fait trop pas à nous après on est
dans le bout d'un quart à marie ensuite
à aubin voilà voilà le vrai dlc
j'analyse déjà les wc de portails portes
la vraie faute ou scanner au nikaïa un
milliard de porte mon gars ya forcément
une porte qui sert à quelque chose
ah c'est pas possible remember what you
je peux même pas dire tellement ces
pixelisé la bulle regarder une autre
le patient a fait une dépression après
avoir été informé de sa mort prochaine
je vais prescrire des antidépresseurs
pour réguler ça mais apparemment j'ai
annulé la prescription et je n'ai aucun
souvenir d'avoir annulé ces médicaments
et je peux pas trouvé de preuve dans mes
commandes
quand tu as moyens photo mh qui a annulé
cette prescription voilà la chute qu'est
ce qu'on a ici
aulas c'est glauque hisser un an c'est
quoi
je peux pas le cas c'est qu'est ce que
c'est que ce bordel on va tenter la
double porte s'est fermée
électroniquement d'accord là c'est juste
un robinet watts à sa sauvegarde qu'on
boit c'est vrai pour écouter d'après mes
calculs c'est forcément au sous sol j'ai
fait les tâches dues aux 126 fois pour
moi la fin seulement ayé note la jac
j'ai pas vu voilà beaucoup plus de
patients qu'avant meurent pour cause de
complications chirurgicales qu'est ce
que font les docteurs la moitié de ces
procédures ne semble complètement pas
nécessaire je connais les docteurs et
les chirurgiens qui sont au dessus de
moi mais il sert probablement des choses
que je ne sais pas tout ça devient très
étrange ok c'est rassurant et ciapa une
clé avec la dot vite of as tu eu plein
ya pas de clé mon gars c'est un truc de
aussi offusqué
je crois que c'est ça
ouais oh là là après autant de porc se
font arrêter un des bâtiments est plein
de portes comme ça un pc va pas on va
pouvoir déverrouiller la porte
électrique ou pas c'est faux apparemment
l'autre mois lui a donné de grosses
doses d'hallucinogènes ils ont rendu la
dépression encore pire il est maintenant
constamment en train de crier et d'avoir
peur à des intervalles aléatoire
j'essayais de filtrer son ensemble pour
en extraire la drogue mais c'était utile
peut-être qu'ils voient démontre cet
homme ou une clé la clé de la salle de
maintenance parfait j'ai été informé que
la procédure pour extraire le voit des
patients est devenu mortel
il n'y a aucune demande de donation et
son état semblait s'améliorer l'équipe
chirurgicale m'a dit que j'avais
personnellement ordonné l'extraction du
foie de cet homme est la pire chose et
que et que j'ai trouvé son x 100 x
entier juste assez sur mon bureau
pardon est ce que ce docteur devient fou
totalement alors on va trouver la salle
de maintenant je crois qu'elle est là
voilà je m'en suis souvenu allons voir
là dedans c'est quoi ça un générateur et
want you back aux agenais et un et je
peux plus la rue mais c'est nickel s'est
rompu ce qu'il nous fallait
trop c'est quoi ça [ __ ] on peut pas
débuter au nom il va nous défoncer la
gueule ou à sauvegarder
voilà ça c'est quoi ça et tous klaxons
singh fritz inside au il bouge
maintenant je me pète h prend les
escaliers direct jabbar v borg a loué au
nom quelle erreur mais quelle erreur
jackson s'offre je cherche voir s'il n'y
a pas un mot c'est quoi métal emblème
pic adobe c'est un emblème en métal qui
se joue en faire et je ressors des
petits as pas le flic au le cri un peu
fébrile on peut le dire j'ai vu de vie
j'ai peu de vie j'ai plus de vie j'ai
plus de vie la plus totale
toi tu es morte à petit on cumulait
alors [ __ ] heureusement j'ai
sauvegardé juste avant mon gars on va
l'esquivé direct à merde en fait on est
obligé de revenir en arrière passée par
là enfin papin elle voit la fin du
labyrinthe chambres d'isolation parfait
a merdé est fermé ok donc faut trouver
une clé dans la mort regarde c'est quoi
ça de l'acide
ah voila voila j'ai vu la sinne là
dessus parfait ok d'accord en fait ça
m'avait téléporter de l'autre côté du
truc vous savez du début lac est
dégueulasse là il faut que je trouve une
clé pour aller dans la chambres
d'isolation au bonjour allait bien mais
dès cet endroit est beaucoup plus grand
que je que je ne le pensais
il est très intéressant pas tellement à
les coutures recruter je suis sûr que tu
vas y arriver
peut-être super merci fois y avait un
mec bien au nickel je vous jure j'ai vu
un monstre bon bah avait vérifié
en bas tu as regardé le voilà voilà
rachetée euros c'est quoi ça j'étais sûr
qu'on allait trouver un truc chelou
c'est flippant écoutez c'est gore n'y a
rien du tout ici alors je me casse oh
voilà c'est ça fallait juste que je cale
ce que j'ai trouvé dans ce tableau au
une trappe secrète alors allons-y cela
ne me l'ait rien de bon par contre
j'suis désolé je proteste là c'est plus
de l'horreur mignonne là ya du sang avec
décapité chelou hockey aux antilles
hammam un petit à main entre amis
tranquillement c'est pas mal allons à
droite un que attila à mons qui veut
nous tuer comme à chaque fois
what happens c'est quoi ce mec ya une
tête de cochon guiboles faut arrêter le
délire elle fait éternuer en plus elle a
un pouvoir a put interview au point de
départ au nom arrête tu es vraiment très
moche [ __ ] c'est infernal j'arrive pas
à trouver la clé du labyrinthe la datar
une mon gars ça fait combien de temps là
que je galère dans le haut bas voilà je
faisais juste de se plaindre un coup
voyez c'est la clé de la chambre
désolation mon pote au alors votre os où
elle est vénère josée verner au il est
énervé des oufs à moi non non
non
non non
mais non je me retaper le labyrinthe qui
dure 15 minutes
c'est vraiment parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
du courage vraiment un jeu tous vêtus
direct maugard a laissé reporte il a
cette fois j'espère pour rater alors
surtout celle où j'étais allé mais je
n'y vais pas c'était à droite je crois
cette fois j'y vais pas seulement si
jamais on voit deux sorcières on se
casse cas
je suis foutu je suis mort n'est
attendue les [ __ ] et voilà non mais
là attendez vous à puce a dû trimer il
met plus de chiffres du mamerow mètres
carrés ça veut rien dire
mauvaise
[Musique]
bah ouais j'en suis fière 27,2 sur le
dlc de spock is out of jobs kers
voilà c'est mes cheveux le jump scare
jeddah plus c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
mes vidéos comme d'habitude je suis
désolé mais là à temps franchement c'est
vraiment trop dur
tu m'as vraiment le truc arrête ou alors
s'entraîner pour cette vidéo merci
d'avoir gardé portez vous bien cas où
tout le monde pis
[Musique]